hi there my name is Gopi Ramanathan and
welcome to say hotel I've been living
here since 2003 I'll start off by
telling you a little bit of our history
it was first known as the third rapids
since French fur traders by it was the
third quad quote rapids that they
encountered coming up from Minneapolis
one of the first settlers was just be
sartell who came here in 1854 from
Massachusetts 1905 dam and paper mill
was built that eventually become verso
paper well the city was incorporated in
1907 in 1925 desert valve corporation
Google starred in startled by Matt to
Zurich from 1907 to 1973 there's a sort
out on almost every city council the
most famous being ripley be ripped out
who was our mayor for about 20 years we
have a presence 17 people on the city's
police department one of one of our most
famous police chiefs was cheap very or
disco in fact he was so famous that
former governor arne carlson declared
december 12 as chief Jerry odish
o'driscoll day speaking of starts all
did you know that sartell is the fastest
growing city in Minnesota and had a 181
percent jump in its population from 1982
two thousand one of our mottos is starts
out alive and growing as fast population
growth is due
Ruth so the fact that we are within a
day's driving truck truck driving
distance from Winnipeg Chicago
Minneapolis Kansas City and st. Louis
when our major employers are desert
converso paper mill we are located on
the Mississippi River and the population
is 14,500 full of upfront if I had to
travel anywhere in the world I would
travel to Australia I've been there
before but it happened so long ago that
I don't really remember it while I'm
there I might visit relatives and the
Olympic Stadium Melbourne Australia hold
the olympics in Melbourne and in Sydney
I would also visit the Sydney Opera
House may look like a monster coming out
of the sea but in fact the architect
designed it so that way it would look
like a peeled orange in Australia's
famous for the outback which is the
deserts in the interior of the country
I'd also like to see some of its
wildlife including the koala koala the
kangaroo and the platypus if I were put
in charge of the earth for an entire day
I'd actually have two top priorities not
just one one of those two is world peace
I'd do that by banning all weapons
there's a lot of mayhem going on this
world right now with natural disasters
like the earthquake in Haiti
and we don't need Wars cause more mayhem
my other priority would be environmental
conservation and I do that by forcing
companies that use fossil fuels to get
some other type of energy like solar or
wind some of our biggest natural
disasters can be linked to global
warming also for those that like snow
like need you would miss snow because
the global warming would raise
temperatures so high that it just would
melt the snow anyways I'm go clear up
nothing
you